Vineyards as far as the eye can see
they nestled on the edges of the forest
facing the Sun
the German cyclists wine route runs
right through the vineyards it combines
nature culture and enjoyment on a 100
kilometer route
yeah we just have to make sure we find
this bend in the wine route where we can
cycle into the vineyards in Devine bag
Anantha
the buds is a region with a very
distinct local cuisine every small
village offers vineyards and traditional
fare Dittus Heim has a very special
reputation the dynasty Mahal hotel and
restaurant is located right on the
market square
it's been known internationally ever
since former German Chancellor Helmut
Kohl invited fellow politicians to dine
here
the Regents hearty sausage and meat
dishes are legendary here they're served
with a modern twist
cuisine in the falls has become a bit
more refined during the past 15 years we
have lots of excellent restaurants here
and it's always worth making a trip to
dine in the region our next stop is
humba a perfect place to sense the
region's turbulent past high above the
village
hum Bach castle built in the 11th
century
it's belonged to Bavaria and to France
and it was destroyed and rebuilt several
times it's been an imperial castle a
Bishop's residence an archive and a ruin
nowadays it houses a museum that
documents an important chapter in German
history when in May 1832 thirty thousand
people marched to the castle they
demanded basic rights freedom and peace
among nations
we follow the German wine route
southwards these vines are more than 400
years old and still supply grapes they
belong to the village of Haute undelete
Boog most villages in the fonts were
laid to waste in the 17th century war of
succession
hold on defeat Boog was an exception so
this winemaking village is a gem with
buildings almost as old as the vines
we stopped a look at Ludwig's fear Villa
when the plants still belonged to
bavaria king ludwig the first had a
summer residence built here it rises
above the vineyards like a gallery with
a panoramic view like the bavarian king
the painter Moxley booked loved the
floods an entire floor here is devoted
to his paintings slave oak is considered
one of the most important
representatives of German Impressionism
wine is the heart and soul of a region
and an important economic factor the
plants is the biggest Riesling grape
growing area in the world I include a
copy next provides visitors can enjoy
one of the many wine-tasting sessions
our trip along the German wine route
ends at the German wine gate in spigen
as soon as you go through it you're in
France
you